hey guys Dave and Gina again where are
we what the hell are we doing click here
and find out Gina take it away alright
so we watch all kinds of stuff online
I'm guilty of watching some of the
sickest crap you could possibly think of
and I love everything about it
but there's one thing what does that
even mean I mean besides people getting
there's one thing that I absolutely
can't do it's not something that's
comfortable for me it's not something
that makes sense to me but everybody
else seems to be clicking on it sharing
it all over Facebook all over my Twitter
feed grief porn that's what they're
calling it do you do you know what that
means is a familiar term for you well
you told me you wanted to talk about
this I do my little research whoa can
you explain that one I can try it's just
such a weird upsetting subject basically
if something let's say a different new
father he loses his wife while she's in
the middle of childbirth and then the
little baby only has what hours to live
because you know some complications
happen so this is literally what
happened so in this father's grief in
this father's absolute darkest hour he
sings to the baby and this gets posted
online and shared millions and millions
of times over with headlines like OMG so
sad oh my heart is breaking oh well and
it's just like shouldn't we be first of
all giving this man his privacy
I don't know who filmed that or if he
knew he was being filmed right but it
makes me super uncomfortable there's so
much here that's related to all the
things that we talked about was mojitos
I'm like a it's a little unclear to me
who filmed that who posted it did
something like 15 million views in like
a week literally watching this man sing
to his child after the wife had died
yeah and then we all see it on Facebook
and we like it and we all it's breaking
my heart and it's like we all want to
get in on all of everything and then
then companies like BuzzFeed and plenty
of other places then they post the video
and then they start profiting from this
awful thing too so we have to watch a
Dewar's ad before you can see this poor
father sing to his dead child yeah
horrible
yeah so it's so layered sound like
companies profiting from this stuff and
then also like our knee
- to share death morrow - which is
obviously a pretty mean or even to feel
something as Extreme as we could
possibly feel it without having to go
through it ourselves seems like to me
because you we've you know I've thrown
this term around before I didn't coin it
I wish I had but we're porn ruined you
know it's like that's why people need to
see crazier stuff with crate because
we're just so desensitized and I think
that's true for emotional stuff - it's
not enough to see it on TV we don't care
if it's a movie of the week with you
know Kristy McNichol we have to see it
in real time you know there's a great
movie one of my favorite movies Running
Man with Arnold Schwarzenegger from the
80s which was a philip k dick short
story I think wait I think I might've
just made that up I think somebody else
but read a lot of Phil ok dick is really
good but about how what they would do is
take make game shows basically out of
criminals and then you'd watch them die
and obviously we're not quite there yet
but this sort of we're sort of getting
there like where we're going to
eventually have executions that are
gonna be videotaped
gladiator-style this has been going on
for thousands and thousands of years and
i and isn't this kind of an extension of
it but flowering it up trying to make
ourselves feel better about it right now
we're we just being jaded people because
we're in the the media thing like what
about all the people that are connecting
and like that able you know if something
terrible happens to you you lose a loved
one and then you're able to post
something it's video and it's cathartic
when my grandma passed away last year I
took a picture in her last hours us
holding each other's hand kind of thing
and yeah he was private and I kind of
struggled with whether I was gonna post
it or not I literally have a very
similar picture on my phone Oh family to
my family members so I understood that's
on your phone privately but I understand
yeah but I struggled it was I gonna put
it on Instagram or not and I did and
then when I got those responses and
people saying so many nice things I mean
it sort of felt like I was honoring her
life something but I think it's a really
interesting yeah it's it's voyeuristic
and unless I can feel good about it
which I can't to be perfectly honest I
haven't watched it I can't watch it yeah
it makes me too uncomfortable I don't
like sad movies I don't like said
anything I don't want to feel that way
so if I don't have the barrier to know
it didn't happen some Yahoo wrote it in
Burbank and this really happened to this
man I don't want to feel
that's just me yeah all right well I
guess we're not gonna watch that steel
magnolias tonight then oh but it's dolly
yeah well dolly dolly you'll deal with
that
yeah dolly what do you guys think of all
this grief porn and sharing all this
stuff is it good is it bad all that
stuff subscribe comment down below all
that fancy stuff